aquí
[Música]
en esta oportunidad les voy a pedir que
cierren los ojos
y se transporte en algún lugar que los
emociones
seguramente se han transportado con esta
persona especial
en este lugar especial
y quiero que se imagínense en dos el uno
al lado del otro y recuerden
recuerden cómo eran sus manos sus gestos
su mirada sus sonrisas que vuelan su
perfume y escuchen su voz recuerden
la palabra recuerdo proviene del latín
recordar y con el prefijo re que
significa nuevo y cordis que significa
corazón entonces será traer de nuevo el
corazón
yo traigo el corazón la ventana de la
casa de mis abuelos esta ventana me
llevo a mi lugar preferido en el mundo
en donde me siento salvo mi refugio es
un lugar en donde siento que los
problemas desaparecen
y me acuerdo como mi abuela me
despertaba cuando por eso entró en el
suelo iluminado toda la pared de la
cocina amarilla
y me decía a mí que mickey despertate y
que íbamos a desayunar
recuerdo cuál era su mesa y qué es lo
que tomaba casi siempre recuerdo ir
tomadas de la mano para ir a comprar y
como a veces nos tomamos 5 minutos
para hablar de cómo viene el seco de mis
amigas del chico que me gustaba y
recuerdo como su voz cambiaba y se
tornaba dulce y tierna cuando ella me
contaba de cómo se enamoró con mi abuelo
ese amor por el abuelo
siempre se reflejó en su mirada y
recuerdo mi abuelo con sus gustos y
bebidas raros esas que hacen con vino el
jugo
recuerdo que era un hombre una persona
trabajadora pero que cada tanto se le
escapa a su niño de adentro y nos
demostrado haciéndonos reír con sus
bailes sus risas sus sonidos raros
y no me quiero olvidar nunca cuando me
acostaba con ellos en invierno para que
me calientan los pies
tampoco quiero olvidarme ese aguante y
ese amor incondicional que se tenía en
el uno con el otro
entonces pienso que recordar es traer de
nuevo el corazón a aquellas emociones
que hacen y no olvidan lo que viví con
ellos
todos tenemos tiempos diferentes y a
veces partimos demasiado pronto por eso
les voy a preguntar abran sus ojos y
miren a su alrededor
a quienes van a dedicar tiempo a su
celular a su trabajo a su pasatiempo y
si en vez de pasar horas y horas
durmiendo jugando a la play o sea lo que
sea que hagas le dedicas 5 minutos a esa
persona que te dedico ahora felicidad
y si te enojaste con tus abuelos porque
no les pides perdón sabes que su tiempo
nos corto que el tuyo pero
increíblemente más valioso y el día que
no estén que vestirán de felicidad
porque se han amado y te amaron juntos
y te dejarán la esencia de vida y esa
persona como los abuelos los llevarás
presentes en aquella bufanda que tejió
la bola
en este lugar en la mesa en donde se
sentaban
en ese sillón en él se sentaba del
abuelo a leer el diario
incluso en alguna frase
y todos tenemos una persona que nos dejó
nos dejará su esencia de vida que nos
dejó la ventana abierta para que el sol
nos ilumine
todos tenemos esta persona que traemos a
diario del corazón
y es que es importante que valoremos a
las personas cuando están antes de que
sea tarde puedo asegurarte que si tienes
esa persona especial al lado tuyo eres
afortunado de haber compartido su gran
amor y no olvides decirle gracias perdón
y cuánto la amas
antes de que sea tarde y si
lamentablemente esa persona no está
contigo
recuerda la bien como era así pueden
contarle a alguien más lo importante que
eran para ustedes y lo bien que les hizo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah